maintenant le docteur jessye norman
alors non seulement vous êtes une des
cantatrices des plus célèbres du monde
c'est vrai mais vous êtes une des
cantatrices les plus honorés combien
avez vous déjà reçu de deux doctorats
honoris causa ou autre cette saison
moi je vous dis on m'a alors harvard
ouais envoyé boston oui mais michigan
university
brandon l'université si vous connaissez
ok j'en ai un deux trois ou j'en ai
d'euros de billets encore deux ça fait
quand même pas mal
apparemment oui alors je vous félicite
pour cela c'est une c'est une une
une décoration un titre qui vous a été
remis ce matin à l'american college of
parisse nous allons voir ça avec vous
patricia avec jessie norman ont été
honorés également et lennar weiler
georges duby et luc montagnier reportage
de marie josée l'hôpital ce matin à
l'université américaine de paris
remise de diplômes de fin des quatre
années d'études une cérémonie à laquelle
professeurs et étudiants assistent en
top 14
les américains appellent comme une
semaine pour signifier sans doute que
c'est aussi le commencement de la vie
adulte
l'entrée dans la carrière à cette
occasion quatre personnalités m'ont
recevoir le diplôme honoris causa
jessye norman la cantatrice et trois
français luc montagnier de l'institut
pasteur georges duby président de la ce
est hélène harvey l'air président du
centre pompidou
charlotte la case doyen de l'université
évoque la carrière de jessye norman qui
chantera la marseillaise le 14 juillet
avant que les autorités universitaires
ne lui confère le titre de docteur
honoris causa en lettres humaines
on voit très bien du petit chapeau vous
avez gardé tous ces chapeaux parce
qu'ils sont tous très différents
alors je sais aussi que vous avez des
décorations des médailles commandeur des
arts et des lettres en france membre
honoraire de la royal academy de londres
c'était incroyable j'ai eu très vite est
il vrai que votre nom a été donné à une
fleur aussi c'est vrai ce oui alors ça
s'appelle l'orchidée jessye norman
oui je crois une dernière chose que vous
êtes donc la chanteuse que nous
connaissons mais où vous avez peur
d'aucune audace je me souviens d'un
formidable clip avec un chanteur qui
s'appelait mercury qui est un chanteur
de rock qu'il a chanté avec le groupe
queen pour barcelona ça vous avez fait
ça et puis alors vous faites la
marseillaise aussi alors ça sera le 14
juillet bien sûr est ce que vous
pourriez nous expliquer comment ça va se
passer
en gros comme ça à l'urgence apportaient
tout leur est arrivé là oui je vais
chanter la marseillaise version berlioz
et à avant et après j en sais rien de
tout non pour la partie qui vous
concerne oui non s'occupera du reste
annoncé mais vous aurez des choristes
avec vous vous aurez des méchantes et
oui tout seul sur la place de la
concorde
synchro web avec micro c'est obligatoire
de sa réponse quand même que ça vous
évoque la marseillaise c'est la liberté
pour tout le monde pas seulement pour
france
mais pour nous tous dans le monde
alors vous avez déjà chanté notre hymne
national jeu
je fais remarquer à ceux qui nous
regardent qu'il va y avoir un compact
disc qui va sortir très bientôt
oui si le premier la marseillaise jessye
norman
alors on va voir une un extrait
ça se passe c'est place vendôme c'est
pas la même place mais c'était avec
daniel bard island mais en tout cas
c'est le même hymne national c'est la
mare si vous regardez regardez couleurs
aussi évidemment reconnaissez
[Musique]
et
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
version berlioz où il fait bien de le
dire
inversion verdure jessye norman ou c'est
qu'en france nous sommes passionnés
d'opéra nous nous disputons d'ailleurs
beaucoup à ce sujet en ce moment à huy
est ce que vous avez envie de venir
chanter dans notre nouvel opéra l'opéra
bastille j'espère un jour vraiment il
faut quand même parce que j'aime
beaucoup chanté en france
j'aime beaucoup chanter à paris et elle
vaut mieux votre dommage ça sera oui
quand même
il a toujours ce genre de nouvelles
salles très moderne et pour la fin de
l'opéra garnier ou bien beaucoup à
l'école ni je trouve ça magnifique mais
peut-être c'est pas pratique
pratiquement c'est dommage parce que
c'est joli c'est vrai ouais tu seras
billet comment le soir du 14 juillet sur
la place de la concorde et là vous aviez
une robe bleu et rouge seulement le
blanc rouge si vous avez une idée de
celui qui vous habillera non pas du tout
ça change quand la france est oui ah bon
les choix alors à tous cas merci oui
alors il faut savoir que jessie norman
le docteur norman encore une fois qu'ils
ont fait ici est hélas c'est que vous
descendez d'un avion faut expliquer ça
ce qui devrait vous arriver là très vite
on suit j'ai chanté avant de guerre soit
et vous êtes là vous en vous prend au
saut du lit et de l'avion alors merci
d'être venus si vite c'est mon plaisir
parler à nous amener merci beaucoup
[Musique]